he's top 10 in the league in that category he's
fourth in goals Here Come the Ducks and silverberg
forces a blocker stop from heluk at the other
end so both teams get an early shot on goal in
the first minute in the M four behind the net
fired in front great pass by Henrik and Jones
sent it wide kept by gudus up the right boards and
Stanley's clear again kept in and huk is going to
cover this one up as that long PID was easily
handled by the veteran net Miner players and
a draft pick going to the Jets in return for
DUIs by follow shot is wide kept by Dello at
the point across for morresy to the top of the
circle Gibson makes a save it pops in the air
Morgan Baron tried to glove it down but couldn't
play it and minakov forced to reverse it quickly
away from pressure Bo Winnipeg just does not give
up the Blue Line easily morrisy again pinching up
the wall forcing the Ducks to clear and change
Dyan Dello brings it through Center and Brendan
Dylan rims it hard around and in shle seals
the wall back to the line long shot from Neil
pan and a big rebound off of Gibson and has five
different times in his career Carlson marches to
Center got it to color stick safe and that was
a fat rebound off of heluk and just steered to
the corner by morresy Ducks able to get it
back Boren lets it go to the line gutus is
open looking for a tip he got it just wide Terry
pursues behind the that Carlson watches color who
brings it back up the boards all the way to the
line he throws it through traffic and it sticks
to hellu talk about Josh Morris he was the second
leading scoring defenseman in the league a season
ago now it's Lowry the captain he shot from
the top of the left Circle Baron able to get
it out Center ice and a regroup for the Ducks
M goes cross ice and OV banine and floats one
in on net tracked by Kyle Connor he moves it
away and a nice breakout for Anaheim as stro
skates it ahead gives it up and gets it back from
patrono curls it to the slot and cars right to
Fowler and hellu has it offensive zone penalties
in particular seem to sap all that momentum away
from him jets are 18th in the league on the
power play and here's a chance for Valar not
sure if Gibson ever saw it doesn't matter eers
gets it to the point and it's kept in by Kyle
Connor right to the front of the net Gibson got
a piece of it because eers was driving to the top
of the crease Conor at his own Blue Line forced
to hit the brakes morisy through the middle gives
it right back now morresy just inside the strike
plays it in behind the net Conor with that Long
Reach tops it in front shley with a couple of
bits from in tight Gibson turns his head never
loses sight of the puck so he sees that short
little dump pass from Connor to shley makes
two good stops against Mark shley protecting the
short side getting down eliminating the bottom of
the net as an option for shley so good work good
head movement good technique show yeah that was
a play where leus can kind of put his defense
partner in a rough spot mikov oh here's a bad
turnover picked off silverberg turns it to the
right of the net and patrono didn't have much of
an angle he just took the shot from the goal line
against tck here's a bad turnover by valard and
silverberg it over for Toronto but he's almost
at the goal line heluk did a good job and you
know I I talked about Conor heluk John a bigger
goal tender Terry brings it off the left boards
down low Jones skate to stick back to Terry Jones
again in his feet Terry in front got a redirect
from color he scores third crack at it and Alex
colar scores three cracks at it before he got
it past well good play by Troy Terry watch Terry
he spots color he throws it down into the crease
there's the tip and it was the second rebound
opportunity what were we talking about rebound
goals the Ducks get a blue collar goal and they
get the lead in this hockey game and that's a
big one and for just the ninth time this season
Anaheim scores first starting to get it going
after missing the first 10 games this season oh
broken stick yeah Fowler couldn't play that puck
tried to get his skate on it Dello looking for
a tiff wires It Wide oh turned over here's aalo
off the goal post blank opportunity immediately
afterwards and Alex aalo rips it off the inside
nice play by bakan at the Blue Line as he was able
to pin his man to the boards trying to Chip and
Chase was bardi the outlet pass to silverberg
nice pass across Henry he scores Adam Henri a
huge goal for the Ducks it's two nothing just over
the glove hand of John Gibson the ducks come the
other way silverberg the timing on the pass to
Henrik was perfect he had some open I vrono who
silently came off the bench and skated right
around Samberg at the point to intercept that
pass carried back in Vlad NES nikov to the
corner tries to beat it in front and it they
score wow neita Rider as his stick was being
tied up by bakan n and in one motion hammers
it just inside the near side post they've got some
life they throw it in front yeah goes off the toe
of the skate of Earl venine and and changes
Direction on John Gibson the very last second
and right through the five hole bouncing tuck
the Troy Terry oh nearly nudged ahead mcin and
Carlson would have been two on0 instead Baron
brings it back in Morris's open his wrist shot
doesn't get through it's in the equipment of
lushin and baron pokes it home Morgan Baron
found it first brand new game Winnipeg is tied
it to two no this is a tough break and then it's
just a race who's going to get a touch on it
but when it hits the ice there's leushin it
drops down he can't find it Morgan Baron just
chops at it and he chops it overneath over top
of the right leg of John Gibson fifth of the
year for the Halifax native Morgan Baron and
what was a two-goal deficit Jackson trying
to make a little pass just inside the line
and that was broken up by shy Lee color gets it
back he's got patrono he'll shoot rebound color
snuffed out still loose as H couldn't cover it
up at both ends Alex color is going to get the
this Puck to Frank patrono and the Ducks battle
hard to keep it alive cuk leaves a rebound can't
cover it up with the catching was pretty much a
nothing play that almost turned in to the go-ahead
goal now here's a turnover Baron marches in gets
him with the save rebound cleared oh patrono hit
a jet with it and it almost went in the net on
his 11th season neita Rider has one of the two
Winnipeg goals tonight he works along the wall
TAPS at three good gets up ended couldn't get
the puck the mnov finds Dello at the point
across to morresy his shot scored tipped
inard bardy as he crossed in front of Gibson got
a piece of that about waist high that angle that
could have been a trip cuz he wasn't making a play
on the puck and here's the redirect by valard boy
one hand on the stick he just reaches out and gets
a little Touch look at that one hand on the stick
and that t dug out by Henrik from below the goal
line in front swatted on net by vrono and a save
by huk 30 seconds left as Lowry puts it into space
shyle skates to it and hits the empty net for what
will be an extremely aggravating loss for the
Ducks tonight it was mnov coming back at the tail
end through his stick in vain in the direction
shle but the shot was long off aalo eats it along
the boards and that'll do it the Jets get the win
here tonight four to two yeah this is a tough one